(upbeat music)
- We're doing a Mega Makeover Hour,
and I'm here with my old dear
friend, Charlotte Tilbury,
who I've known for how long, Charlotte?
- Oh my God. I think it's 20 plus years.
- Yeah.
We're working with 25 teachers
which is the group of--
- Oh my God, it's been so
emotional getting them ready.
Like I've nearly been in
tears a couple of times, like.
They're like, I've never
seen my eyes look like this,
I've never seen my skin.
It's like, and you are like,
so amazing, these women, seeing-
- And Chris Appleton, who
I'm going to do hair with,
who's doing everybody here,
he makes hair for cancer
patients and wigs,
and he has always been such a good person.
And for me, makeup and hair
has never been about vanity.
It's about empowerment.
- It's all about empowerment,
because it's all,
what I always say is
we're selling feelings.
- Yes!
- Feelings.
- And even more interesting I find
is the second you think you're okay,
and you're taken care of
is where you get bigger and
better for everyone else.
- Exactly.
- It's like, I'm fine.
- I'm not insecure.
I'm not wrapped up in my own thoughts.
I'm set free to then be
outward, bigger, and better.
- And that's why I am so
grateful to do what I do,
and have this on,
because I really started that this
because I was like I
want democratize makeup,
because I always had you in my chair,
or you know, all the celebrities
I worked within the world.
But actually I wanted
to give it to everyone.
Make it quick, make it easy.
- And you did, Charlotte.
Give it to everyone.
But you know that, darling.
- Remember when you told
me you were launching,
and I was like, "Okay."
- [Charlotte] Do you remember?
- Oh my God.
I remember you were like,
"I want to make velvet
chairs in this whole world,
"and like this feeling
and this whole setting."
- And you too, darling,
Flower's amazing.
- Oh, thank you.
- It is.
And that's what I want to do
with the show is a feeling.
- It's a feeling.
- It's the Maya Angelou quote.
It's not what people think of you.
It's how you make them feel.
- And feel.
Invest all your stock in feelings.
- In feelings.
(upbeat music)
- Chris, at what point
can I give you my head?
'Cause I'm all yours, too.
- [Chris] Yeah, I'm ready, babe!
Whenever you want.
- Do it, get in there.
- Okay.
- I am your clay.
- [Chris] Oh, I love it.
- This is the most action I've
had in six years, Charlotte.
Bring it on.
(Charlotte laughs)
That's not caught on camera.
I'm like, luckily there
are cameras, but yeah.
It is so hard.
Men never ask women out.
- [Charlotte] Yeah, yeah,
go, go, go, keep going.
- [Chris] Are we talking about dating?
- [Drew] Huh?
- [Chris] About dating?
- [Drew] Yes.
- [Chris] It's really hard.
- [Charlotte] The amount of men that
want to probably date you, like.
- I'm happier alone.
- Oh, but you see, you're
telling the universe
you're happy alone, and I think-
- [Drew] Oh, here we go.
- [Charlotte] You are not.
So 'cause the fact is,
(Chris laughs)
the fact is-
- You tell her.
- You are hot sexy,
gorgeous, totally inspiring,
and you deserve to
share that with someone.
- I do have kids too,
which makes a huge difference,
and the fact that like.
- But what-
At least I have a great love.
- Oh God, you have a great love,
but you can have it all, Drew.
You know that.
You have whatever you manifest.
- Said from the woman who I believe does,
so I'm looking at it.
- Oh listen.
I've, you know, I always thought
why do we have to limit ourselves?
We can't just be have amazing careers.
We can have it all.
We can have kids.
(upbeat music)
We have got a beautiful lady.
- [Drew] Oh my God.
- [Charlotte] In our chair.
- [Chris] This is light work.
- [Charlotte] Making it light work.
- Light work.
- I know, easy breezy.
- An old, an old horse.
(Drew whinnies)
(upbeat music)
- I'm getting final touches.
I'm going to go in the other
room, throw something on,
and then we're going
downstairs to do this.
Welcome to our Mega Makeover Hour!
(audience cheers and applauds)
I'm walking, living proof.
I mean, look at me.
I keep walking past a mirror
and being like, "Who is that?"
I just thank you,
'cause this is so meaningful for me
to be a part of this Mega
Makeover Hour with you guys.
Thank you, really and truly.
- Really, truly thank you.
(audience applauds)